AG T's Courtney had when summons the
rock gods for another earth-shattering
performance Breanna hints new music is
coming as the AMA nominations are
announced but who got snuck Plus Henry
Cavill appears to be out as Superman
back and I missed you guys
special shout out to Courtney tez no and
Holly Stevens her filling in on the
daily Denny while I was out on
assignment got some fun things cooking
for you guys but I got back just in time
for last night's America's Got Talent
it's the semi-finals
[Music]
where the judges were once again blown
away by fourteen-year-old force of
nature courtney hadwin
[Laughter]
[Music]
how do you feel let's start there say
you were overwhelmed after the first
performance you're overwhelmed after the
golden buzzer performance do you feel
like you're getting used to all of this
attention and all this kind of response
for your voice then when I step back
down I'm doing it all over again
I just starts right back up right we saw
that backstage you were shaking how
nervous were you before you hit that
stage tonight one step closer to the
final and like idml be one step closer
to the final and I just had to step it
off do you feel how much pressure do you
feel knowing that you're also closing
out the show because that's a coveted
spot like in the in the actual show you
know you were on your feet for Courtney
I don't want to sit down until the
finals because I think that she's gonna
have the confetti going for her one more
time I mean what's it gonna take for her
to cross that finish line though I think
it's just embracing don't think about
and she doesn't and that's why she is
different than anybody her age anybody
in music right now just you do you and
that's what I say to Courtney she's
amazing
[Music]
I am convinced there is a ghost living
in that girl's body I swear
Kourtney's possessed machine hits that
stage which is why it's so amazing to
watch but there were some other
standouts last night giving Courtney a
run for her money
including my boy Brian King Joseph who
I'm telling you the guys meant for Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
also Glennis grace later cover of this
woman's work and I was watching her
thinking oh she's not going down without
a fight
[Music]
she's a dark horse in this race but I do
want to know from you guys who are you
rooting for
next week is the finale so we'll have to
wait and see who the next winner of a GT
is but something we've been waiting a
lot longer for Rihanna's next album it's
been well over two years since RiRi put
out anti so where's the new stuff
well the 30 year old singer teased it
isn't too far away when she responded to
a fan on Instagram about her next album
quote I know I know says I'm doing music
simultaneously doing lingerie makeup
film amongst a couple other things that
I enjoy she added when the music is
ready you won't have to ask for it but
it's coming just not today
I'm hype too though it can't come soon
enough but you're not wrong read the
Navy is waiting for our 9 I've waited
long enough for this ninth album but
something does tell me we'll get it
maybe early next year if not sooner and
I'm predicting it right now you guys she
is going to headline Coachella in 2019
write that down right in the meantime if
lingerie is more your kind of thing
Rihanna is set to debut her latest
savage expensi collection at New York
Fashion Week that's streaming live on
YouTube at 7:30 Eastern I mean while
Marie's work co-star Drake dominated
today's American Music Award nominations
he ties for most nominated artists along
with cardi B they both earned eight AMA
nominations this morning and interesting
to note guys that cardies nemesis Nicki
Minaj yeah she was shut out completely
with 0 nominations switching gears now
to a shake-up in the DC Universe Henry
Cavill appears to be hanging up his
Superman cape after playing the Man of
Steel for three films now according to
The Hollywood Reporter it all started
after Warner Brothers tried to make a
Superman cameo happen in the upcoming
Shazam movie who exactly Levi's but that
didn't happen as contract talks broke
down and now the studio is reportedly
hitting pause on any new Superman films
instead shifting their focus to a
Supergirl movie now Warner Brothers did
release a statement today saying well no
decisions have been made regarding any
upcoming Superman films we've always had
great respect for and a great
relationship with Henry Cavill and that
remains unchanged and in fact you guys
you know actually Henry's manager
tweeted this morning to fans
be peaceful the Cape is still in his
closet Warner Brothers has been and
continues to be our partners as they
evolve the DC Universe right time will
tell guys but what do you make of this
DC shake-up can the Justice League
franchise stand without anymore Superman
films and if not who should play the Man
of Steel if Henry is out Haller in the
comments section I want to know what you
guys think are we have more on this
story up on ET online.com and be sure to
check out more of my interviews from AGT
and i'll see you guys tomorrow with war
daily denne
[Music]